one of the primary aims of the scp
foundation
is to contain the anomalies that they
discover secure
contain protect is their mission
statement after all
however there are some forces so
unknowable and malevolent that there is
no way to truly
contain them scp-4205 is one such
force very little is known about
scp-4205
even compared to other scps many of
which are mysterious by their very
nature
we do not know what it is we do not know
what it wants
and we do not have any meaningful way to
stop it
the best that can be done to protect
yourself from it is to implement the few
known preventative measures available
and pray that it doesn't set its sights
on you
the little information that exists on
scp-4205 was recorded by wade dallets
a former junior researcher at the
foundation he wrote the initial report
on scp-4205 on a computer
terminal four though his work was highly
valuable and provided many previously
unknown insights about the nature of the
scp
sadly his knowledge could not save him
the official entry on scp-4205 was his
final act before his death
on december 11 1992.
before we get deeper into that entry and
wade's final day on earth
it's important to understand what
scp-420
is or at least understand the little we
know about what it is
4205 is a ketter class scp meaning that
it's incredibly difficult or complicated
to contain
it also shows extreme hostility toward
all life
it is described as an amber colored pair
of human-like eyes
with the ability to appear spontaneously
in windows
mirrors or any other glass or glass-like
surface
one of the reasons so little is known
about these eyes is that anyone who sees
them
dies within seconds much like the
mythical basilisk
the gaze of scp-4205 is deadly and
inescapable the eyes only seem to appear
to people who are alone in a room
and never in places where there's more
than one person
but aside from that there is no way to
predict where the eyes will appear
since it is unknown if the eyes are part
of a corporeal body or even present on
this plane of reality
there is no way to contain them or stop
them from killing
this brings us to that fateful day
december 11
1992 the day that the scp foundation
would finally be given some tangible
information on the mysterious amber eyes
at the cost of one of their researchers
lives
wade dallas a young man fresh out of his
university studies was brought on board
as a junior researcher by dr mark
forsythe
a senior researcher dr forsythe
recruited wade after giving a guest
lecture at his university
and being impressed by wade's keen
observational skills
thirst for knowledge of the unexplained
and determination to understand that
which seemed to defy
explanation after wade graduated he was
recruited by dr forsythe
and given the position of junior
researcher at the scp foundation
where he assisted dr forsythe now a site
supervisor
in his research after several months of
working under dr forsythe with minimal
responsibilities
wade was finally given the opportunity
to write his first scp
report on scp-4205
following some initial documented
appearances of 4205
dr forsyth approved further research
into the anomaly
with wade appointed as the lead
researcher on the subject
according to wade's entry he was
responsible for the discovery of
scp-4205 when he spotted the anomaly in
a window
the later reviews of security footage
determined that he was not the first
person to observe the eyes
he did claim to be the first to observe
them and live to tell the tale
in his writing on the subject wade is
puzzled by the fact that he survived his
encounter with scp-4205
and wonders what could have set him
apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze
he found himself frustrated as he
documented scp-4205
his rough drafts of reports dissolving
into angry rants about his own
incompetence
wayne had difficulty adjusting to his
new responsibilities
especially with the added element of his
assigned subject's mysterious and
volatile nature
in between his reports on scp-4205
its previous appearances and its effects
on its victims
he wrote letters to his father desperate
for reassurance that he was not messing
everything up
letters that would sadly go unsent in
his coverage of scp-4204
wade made note of a troubling recurring
element in each victim's death
when medical professionals attempted to
revive the victims it was always noted
that their brain activity stopped much
more quickly than in cases of death by
natural causes
when examined all aspects of the body
aside from the brain were completely
unharmed
the brain however showed massive nerve
damage in the amygdala hippocampus
medial temporal lobe and occipital lobe
the appearance of this brain trauma had
been compared to the effects of
electrical shock or severe head injury
in addition to wade six other people on
record encountered scp-4205
every encounter ended the same way with
sudden brain death and severe nerve
damage
immediately after viewing the eyes in a
reflective surface
the first encounter occurred on january
5th 1990
when deputy lia zangena viewed the eyes
in a reflective glass one-way window
security tape reveals that the eyes
appeared in the window eight minutes
before the deputy liaison spotted them
as soon as he did he fell from his chair
and immediately died
though the specifics varied from case to
case the end result of every encounter
was the same
with none surviving long enough to
relate what they had experienced
every encounter except wades as he
continued his documentation of scp-4205
wade's mental state quickly began to
deteriorate
the process of his mind coming apart and
his thoughts giving way to confusion
fear and anger at his own survival is
documented in his reports on the scp
he agonized over the questions of why he
was able to survive
gazing into the eyes of scp-4205
when so many others had not the question
consumed him until he was unable to eat
sleep or do anything but obsess over the
scp he was tasked with researching
as he became more agitated he began to
write about the eyes appearing to him
again on one occurrence he attempted to
touch them
and described the sensation like
touching a balloon to your arm
after it had been charged with static
electricity he continued to report
seeing the eyes
the worse was when trying to sleep
during which she was
overtaken by violent sleep paralysis and
plagued with visions of the amber eyes
the only comfort wade seemed to find was
in memories of his loved ones
he wrote about his mother and his father
even as their memories grew foggier to
him
he also mentioned a man by the name of
theodor quail
who he claimed was a researcher at the
foundation later fact-checking
determined that this was not the case
and that quail must have been someone
from wade's past he wrote about quail
wistfully
mournfully with words of love and loss
tormented by the sense that he was
losing his grip on reality
and everything he once held dear as wade
descended deeper into a hell inside his
own mind
he continued to mull over the questions
of scp-4204
was there more to it than what was
visible did it have a body
why had he survived the encounter with
it and what did it want from him
he decided that those who had perished
immediately were the lucky ones
they had escaped the torture that had
overtaken his life
the eyes were everywhere now watching
him even as he attempted to unlock their
secrets on a foundation computer
he spoke to the eyes at one point but
refused to write down what they said to
him
his last entry his last thought was a
plea for theodore quayle's embrace
there is no more written about the
research or about the eyes
only a simple desperate need for a
comfort that is long
lost now is the part of our story where
terror meets tragedy
contrary to what wade thought and what
was recorded in his final computer
entries
he did not survive his brief brush with
scp-4205
the truth is that he spotted the amber
eyes in the glass above his terminal
monitor while recording the entry
and died seconds later though his death
was swift
it felt agonizingly slow as revealed by
his descent into panic and paranoia
recorded in his writings
the entries recorded as a result of the
connection weighed in the computer
his physical contact with it at the
moment of exposure to scp-4205's
anomalous effects
allowing the terminal to archive his
final thoughts
before he succumbed to the deadly nature
of the eyes
the entries were never physically typed
but rather jump from his dying mind
into the mainframe his entries the
echoes of a dying mind
offer a glimpse into the way that
scp-4205 kills its victims
in the seconds leading up to death the
amber eyes fast forward a person's mind
feeding on the electrical impulses that
it gives off as it speeds through what
seems to be days of fear
and of a loosening grip on reality the
death may be swift
but the suffering is long wade left the
foundation with a digital fingerprint
an echo of the person he was at his core
in addition to his experiences with
scp-4205 itself
wade spent his final moments terrified
for his life
dreaming of a father that he missed and
a long lost love from his college days
his sacrifice must not be forgotten
because no one ever survives an
encounter with scp-4205
his documented final moments are the
only first-hand account
in existence junior researcher wade
dalets gave us a gift
in death he allowed the scp foundation a
glimpse
into the true horror of the amber eyes
and a reminder of what they are capable
of stealing from us
so be careful of windows mirrors screens
and all reflective surfaces
when you look into them you never know
what you might see
looking back check out scp-3008
trapped in ikea and scp-5000 the suit
for more from the archives of the scp
foundation